[Music]
our series what's working looks at
innovations that are paying off in
America from education to infrastructure
about 1/4 of today's college students
admit they suffer consequences from
drinking too much nearly 700,000 people
say they've been assaulted by another
student who had too much alcohol a major
university is turning to neuroscience to
encourage kids to tap into their books
instead of kegs Jim Axelrod visited what
that campus to see this program in
action Jim good morning I think this is
one of my favorite stories I'm excited
to hear it it's interesting good morning
to everybody we went to the University
of Vermont long-known is a big-time
party school to see its new approach
that combines cutting-edge neuroscience
with age-old incentives to build
students brains both inside and outside
the classroom and in the process turn
the old College keg stand on its head
you know it's not your average college
dorm when violins can be found on every
floor but alcohol and pot are nowhere to
be seen
this brain is sitting there going feed
me
psychiatry professor Jim hood jack
pulled a few strings filming this
freshman dorm with 80 violins while
requiring students to sign this contract
no drinking or drugs if they want to
live here a bold experiment on any
college campus but he did it here but we
didn't go do it in a place where
everyone would say oh that would work we
did it in a place where people giggled
at the University of Vermont senior cow
Rollins this reputation had had as a
party school yeah I was the word I would
say yeah but for students not interested
in Animal House Thanks I needed that
welcome to the wellness environment they
call us a cult they call me a narc they
say like wellness environments no fun
it's so strict at this program for
incoming freshmen it's goodbye toga
hello yoga late night pizza and
round-the-clock partying have been
replaced by peloton bikes and personal
trainers the idea surrounds students
with activities that expand the brain
not zap it with the usual menu of
college indulgences I remember even
learning that you you're supposed to be
probiotic yogurt to help your brain
function probiotic yogurt yeah helps
your brain function dr. hoods Yahoo yeah
he'll reinforce that again and again
yeah and it's working binge drinking is
down GPAs and graduation rates are up
the program has grown tenfold in just
four years to almost a third of this
year's entering class you couldn't come
up with a worse age to send someone to
college than when there are 18 it's the
most vulnerable brain period other than
0 to 3 the brain is not done developing
at 18 not even close
so what we're gonna do so Doctor Who
Jack the chief of child psychiatry at
UVM's Medical School set some rules no
bonds or beer pong no shot glasses or
lighters what he calls neuro triggers
that tempt bad behavior the kids in my
community aren't punished if they go out
and have a beer or smoke the dilly weed
it's just not allowed in their dorm
rooms hood jack frames it as an exercise
in making choices handing out Apple
watches for students to record the
consequences they could say well I've
had three bad days and then they can
look at their own Health Survey and go
well I smoked six bowls had five shots
and didn't sleep very much maybe that's
why for all of us there's an application
absolutely you build a healthy brain a
healthy body will follow just begin to
feel your body standing meditation and
exercise have become the activities of
choice and this doctors prescriptions
are for belly breathing and reading
Harry Potter and the Chamber of Secrets
this is not the
ramblings of a crunchy Vermonter this is
hardcore neuroscience and now the core
of a new approach that's working I
learned all of those healthy habits that
I know I need to succeed from this
wellness environment including the
knowledge that college is a time too
precious to be wasted
now the approach they're taking at UVM
is really catching on so big schools
like NYU here in New York have started
similar programs and more than 40 others
have expressed interest in bringing this
approach back to their campuses I mean
I'm sure I'm like many of you I was 18
when I went off to college but I was
about 12 if you measured by putting to
her brain you see something like this
like Noor and I at the same time said
what's his name yeah dr. Jim has the AK
right just talked about neuroscience
building good habits but the connection
between health wellness and elegance and
also stretch the director of the CDC dr.
Redfield said that for the opioid crisis
what you need to do is teach people to
short-circuit they're stressed with
healthy things so that they don't turn
to unhealthy things but for college
students his genius he's not wagging a
finger yeah let's try this let's try
yoga let's try keeping track of stuff
different the results seem to speak for
themselves Oh Jim it's working the m2
website may be crashing we're watching
the dinner